you know when we talk about
live your quest that's a really
big statement it can be exciting
and scary anybody have that mutual
feeling at times you like live my quest
i'm just trying to figure out my gps
trying to figure out what does next year
look like
you know and then there's that
opportunity that comes with living your
quest to go wait a minute
what happens if i decided and design my
next best season
what would that look like i wake up in
the morning to find out how can i
disrupt anything that's not in alignment
with my future today
and so since i'm on the stage today i
thought i'll just do that with you guys
as well is that all right
when we talk about living our quest
um i think that living my quest
really if i look at on a daily basis
it's finding my own voice
it's finding your voice it's finding the
song that
only you can sing off-key or not
it's finding your rhythm it's
discovering what it feels like to walk
in your shoes today it won't look like
it looked ten years ago
living your quest is
what can i do with my life so that my
life becomes infectious to someone else
living my quest looks like how do i
make my fingerprint matter so big that
it lives beyond my transition day
living your quest is how can i forgive
the perceivingly unforgivable so i can
love the absolute lovable
living your quest is how do i
give myself a thousand second chances
and every time i get to 9.99 press reset
yeah yeah
living my quest is is not some ambiguous
untouchable experience living my quest
means going back and healing the little
girl in me
so that the woman can be free it's going
back and embracing
the little boy in you so that the man
can show up and give himself permission
to cry when necessary
living your quest is not something that
you can't touch
it's not something that requires a stage
or lights or cameras
living your quest is being completely
content with who you
are in the dark of the night so who you
are in the middle of the day is
all right living your quest is
as simple as it is complex
living your quest is about giving
yourself permission say permission
on a daily basis to become the next
best version of yourself living your
quest is
not holding yourself hostage to old
decisions
not holding yourself hostage to shame
blame guilt regret
and anger living your quest is about
recognizing that every day i can be
reborn to my possibility
see living your quest is as internal and
personal as it is public
living your quest is about recognizing
that you have
brilliance in you and not being willing
to dim your light
one more day living your quest means
not being afraid of the genius in you
even though you have doubt
living your quest is recognizing that
you get to sing your song
off tune that you can get to live in
perfection while you
master imperfection living your quest
is it could be complex and it could be
simple
and i'm only telling you the things that
i've had to do
because in so many ways i didn't know i
would be
standing here with you in cancun
my path didn't make sense that it would
land me here
i look at my life as a young woman in
south central l.a living between the
harlem crypt 30s and the rolling 60s
those are not cheerleading squads y'all
having three fights a week to get home
from school and that was the easy part
the hard part was the fact that my
highest grade in school
was a c-plus see when some of you
brought home c's your parents were
frustrated
when i brought homerc my parents were
excited because i was severely dyslexic
in school
so i it took me a lot longer to learn
the last time i took an english class i
got a fail and my english teacher said
lisa you have to be the weakest writer
i've ever met in my entire life
i said does that come with an award i am
kind of collecting rewards
and the last time i took a speech class
my speech teacher gave me a d-minus
and said quote-unquote miss nichols i
recommend that you never speak in public
that you get a death job
and what it showed me was that some of
your best motivation might come wrapped
in sandpaper
some of your best inspiration comes with
some pricks and some nails and some
thorns around it
some of your best inspiration came in an
experience that you didn't ask for you
didn't want and you'd never want to have
again
some of your best inspiration some of
the very thing that's fueled your soul
to get you here
came in an experience that you dare not
wish on your enemy
i want to talk about doing you
unapologetically
no longer dimming your light you know
this is something that i
lived with and in many cases struggled
with for years
you know how you can recognize very
early on that
there's something unique about you you
walk into a room
and what we tend to do when we walk into
a room is we measure and we calibrate
ourselves based on where the room is
to make sure we don't outshine the room
come on type in chat
yana or yes that's me or yes yes you see
the sign yes yes that's me
if that's been you i would walk into
rooms
even in middle school even in elementary
school and for sure by the time i got to
high school
and i didn't even know that i was doing
it i would unconsciously
step into a room and check to see if i
can do
lisa or what percentage of lisa could i
do
i rarely walked into a room and gave
them 100
of me because i didn't want to outshine
the room i didn't want to out
energy the room i didn't want to do
something i didn't want to stand
out in the room i just wanted to be
accepted
i realized that i wanted to be accepted
more than i wanted to do me
is that you have you ever been there
are you there right now when i would go
to family functions i would calibrate
calibrate my energy based on my family
members
when i would go to meetings i'd
calibrate my energy calibrate my life
adjust my light turn my light down based
on who else was in the room
when i was at a track meet or when i was
in theater on dance
i would adjust myself to make sure i
didn't stand out
i was more committed to fitting in than
i was to doing lisa
you know does that sound familiar at all
yanami let me know lisa you are not
alone
and so this episode is about that thing
you already know
you are an unrepeatable miracle
no one on this planet can do you
and what my reverend dr michael beckwith
said and if you don't do you you won't
be done
that was delicious when i heard it at my
summit
if you don't do you then you won't be
done there's only one person that can
give us you
and you don't give us any benefit you
don't you're you're not giving us a
bonus
when you step into our space and you
measure the energy and you
tone down your light you tone down your
brilliance
you turn down your beauty so that we
won't feel insecure and uncomfortable in
your presence
you're not doing anyone a favor so i'm
gonna say to you sis
i wanna say to you brother i'm going to
challenge and charge you
when you step into that next room
wherever that room is
whether it's your home whether it's your
business whether it's a
a virtual room whether it's online
whether it's on zoom
whether is on facebook live wherever you
are
i'm going to challenge you to give us
the best version of you because when you
let your light shine
you have no idea how your light can
become
contagious and could lighten up what
could have been a dark moment for me
but i need you to shine your light as
brightly as you can
so that i can pick up a glimmer of who i
can become
i'm not gonna try to do you but i need
to be able to see in your light
a better version of me a more solid me
i stopped by to ask are you willing to
play so big
that you scare yourself are you willing
to sing so loudly that the next room
stops are you willing to dance in such a
rhythm
that you become contagious are you
willing to forgive the unforgivable love
the unlovable
are you willing to do it all a thousand
times until you get it right
are you willing like i just stopped by
because that's what it feels like
on a daily basis to recommit to the
divine assignment on your life
because your life has less to do with
you
than it has to do with all of us who
will cross your path
and because you let your light shine
you gave us permission to do the same
because we saw you do it
with knees knocking and teeth chattering
but you did it anyway we just become
copycats of you well he did it
i might as well do it and all of a
sudden an entire nation
is doing something bold and outrageous
and radical if you're an environment
that's negative
and you can't move right now
number one i would say to brandon and to
bruno
and anyone else who needs to hear this
message
that your now is not your forever
so it's important right now for you to
do that thing that i used to always do
when i was
living in inglewood and i love inglewood
nothing's wrong with any wood
i just had a lot of chaos in my life
when i lived there
um i kept reminding myself what i
will recommend that you remind yourself
there
is a light at the end
of the tunnel and it's not
a train coming at you it really is light
now sometimes the light is glaring and
it's big
because it's closer right and sometimes
the light is a
just an absolute flicker
because it's further off right your job
is to know you might not be able to
run like an olympic athlete that
fast you may not be able to trot
some days you're just doing a walk right
and some days you might just be doing a
crawl but if you
keep putting one foot in front of the
other if you
keep doing it it's not about your speed
right
it's about your consistency you keep
checking into this channel
you keep your keep hooking your caboose
to trains like this
trains like you then that one step
one step you know i can't remember the
who said this quote
uh forgive me but they say the journey
of ten thousand miles starts with one
step
right you know i think i know who it is
but just because i'm not clear i won't
say it i won't guess
but you can get 10 000 miles right
one step at a time yeah it's gonna take
us a while
right but you got a while you're gonna
get older anyway
why not use that time taking a step
in the right direction you know this
time in my life
is like i hear people say surreal
and for years i number one i didn't know
what surreal meant
i guess because i didn't have a lot of
surreal moments i had a lot of real
moments
lace with struggle and doubt and
questioning and now i understand surreal
surreal is when you
for me i'm living inside my own life
experience blown away
by what my life experience is i i'll
i'll never forget that my first
office was in a walk-in closet that you
really couldn't walk in it was kind of
step in and turn
i'll never forget that i know exactly
where it was i could see the
closet in my head or my office
so when i look around and i see the
growth
it truly cements
that your resiliency and your willpower
is greater than any circumstance around
you
like that's what this tells me that's
when i look around and i
i see you guys i see my team i i hear
jaylani talk about how
he was on a team meeting and each of the
team members
um in my company were reciting a guiding
principle
and how he could hear me in the guiding
principles
but i wasn't there i was i was on
vacation
that's powerful because for so long it
was lonely
for so long i couldn't i couldn't have
anyone join the journey with me because
i was still trying to define what it was
so it just shows me that you can have
something in your head
and for a while no one else has to get
your vision we
i used to get upset because i felt like
no one got my vision well no one got my
vision because god didn't give my vision
to them god gave my vision to me
and it was my job to birth the vision so
that you can show up matt and john can
show up
and david and my family could have this
experience
and and it was exactly the way it was
supposed to be
like every early morning and every long
night every moment
oh my god it's been 20 years and i can't
tell you how many times i thought
i'm just about out of business right now
like yep
i'm gonna be out of business in 30 days
like i had so many
30 days from out of business
30 30 minutes from out of business
uh i have no idea how to pay that bill
just so many of those
and the one common denominator that i
could say
every time was
i raised my wheel greater than the
circumstance
i dug deeper in my resiliency than i was
in debt
like i was in deep debt but i had deeper
resiliency
and so that's why i'm on fire i'm on
fire for teaching people how
not to stay standing up but how to
how to master getting back up how to
master
bouncing back how to then master running
and soaring and so it's
dare i say surreal dare i say
i'm unbelievably true
and i stopped asking myself was i worthy
of this like i'm at a place
where i'm not in an internal battle
of the why me how me god are you sure me
for a long time i was living in an
external success
but i had so much internal doubt that
i'm the right person for it
i have peace i look around
i look at the pictures of nelson mandela
and
and martin luther king i look at my
sisters behind me i
i look at the environment and i go no
i didn't land here i climbed here
like i wasn't helicopter landed on this
mountain top
i got the glutes i got the abs i got the
quads
i got the biceps and the triceps though
i'd
i'm working on them all still i got the
muscle memory
that remembers the climb
so i just i'm at peace
with my imperfection and today i'm at
peace with my brilliance
there is no plan b just keep tweaking
plan a
my past does not equal my future
your past does not equal your future
yesterday does not equal today or
tomorrow it's a setup
for today or tomorrow so my mistakes of
last month last year
or 30 minutes ago does not define my
next decision
reinvention reinvention
is available to everybody every day
reset restart
recommit recharge
redesign it like that re-re-re-re has
been my life
restarted redesigned it recommit to it
re-dedicate go somewhere recharge
redirect all of that
saved me 30 minutes away from closing my
doors
30 days away from shutting down my
business
three months away from quitting it all
and then i'd stop and recommit
i'd redesign the strategy i'd release
the old strategy that wasn't working i'd
ask for help
to spend so many 30 days away from
closing the doors
and it's been 20 years i'ma say
something that might disrupt people but
that's who i am
your ego wants to know about the finish
line first that's
ego that's and it actually is more
selfish than service
so it's saying if i know where i'm going
and if i know that it's going to work
and if
i like how it's going to end up then
i'll play full out
what do you think martin luther king
played like that do you think
harriet tubman rosa parks do you think
oprah played like that
like these individuals said i'm gonna
play full out and so
when you say i'm going to do it
i'm willing to live in the unknown i'm
willing to confront the unc
by the way the unknown is uncomfortable
for all of us so don't think that i'm
backstroking
in the unknown and i love it but you
have to be more obedient
you have to be more living in your
conviction to be a disruption to the way
life
is today and and here's what i i
realized
people want to get clear before they
fully get in action and that's what
you're seeing right now
people want to get clear before they
fully get in action well guess what
clarity follows action so when you get
an action
clarity is revealed so people are
waiting i'm gonna wait i'm just i'm
gonna wait i'm gonna wait till i get
clear to full
to play full out i'm gonna wait till i
get clear and then
clarity is going i'm just gonna wait
until you get an action to reveal some
more clarity to you
because clarity isn't revealed from a
dump truck
clarity is revealed in a spoonful but
you have to be in
action with the previous spoonful that
you received
in order to get the next one full so
you're trying to see 2 000
miles down the road and 2 000 miles is
waiting for you to take 200 steps
this particular lesson i'm not just
bringing to you because i know it i'm
bringing it to you because i
struggle with it for so long see
in my world being disciplined and
creating motivating the masses
it meant grinding every day raise your
hand
type in chat if you say yana you are not
alone if you are a grinder like i was
on the treadmill every morning not
physically but figuratively
i was on the working creating developing
lisa
developing motivating the masses
treadmill every single day
16 17 hour days seven days a week i take
a little break on sunday but i
put in at least five to six hours on
sunday i put
everything aside for the sake of
building
the dream building the machine
building the brand building the message
building
building building building and while
that's necessary it's so important for
you to have the discipline
of consistency the discipline of putting
the units of
time in whether you're doing research
and development
whether you're doing practice and
operation whether you're doing
debriefing and assessment
whether you're doing implementation
whatever it is you're doing and building
your dream
it's important to have the discipline to
be consistent
in that practice that's important
consistency is going to bring about
results it's going to give you great
results or it's going to give you great
lessons
and either one you need however
the area that i lacked in was the
area of practicing self-care raise your
hand as self-care is the muscle that
still
and atrophy you don't have you've seen
popeye this might date you if you're old
enough to know about popeye then we're
in the same
zone you know popeye will put a muscle
up and the muscle will be nice and round
and olive oil will put the muscle up and
the muscle would hang from the bottom
and just kind of
wiggle well my disciplined muscle to
build
the business to build the dream was a
popeye muscle it was solid
not going anywhere hold on was that
solid okay yeah
it was solid it wasn't going anywhere
but my olive oil muscle was the muscle
of practicing self-care
so if i'm going to teach you and inspire
you to do anything i'm going to say
don't do it like i did it do it like i
learned how to do it
self-care is as important to your dream
as getting on the treadmill of making
sales calls getting on the treadmill of
being consistent on social media getting
on the treadmill of knowing your numbers
and your projections getting on the
treadmills and mastering your craft
that the the act of self-care
is just as important because realize
that
what you're doing is not a sprint you're
not building something that's short-term
you're building something that's a
marathon
you're building a long haul you want the
work you do now
to turn around and serve people in the
next 20 years whether you're still at it
or not
so self-care is not optional nor is
self-care
selfish self-care is your responsibility
to your future as you're disciplined
enough to learn new techniques
implement new techniques make sure that
you're also disciplined in self-care now
let me be clear
self-care does not mean balance balance
is a myth
and harmony is a must what do i mean by
that you'll never
rest for the same amount of time that
you work if you're a go-getter if you're
like me if you're a gladiator or a
change agent and moving in shape
a mover and shaker then everything is
not equal
but you can learn how to get what you
need out of the time that you put into
self-care
self-care is the act of restoring your
soul restoring your cells
restoring your energy self-care is not
necessarily
a practice of something doing self-care
is also the practice of being
being present to your family being
present to your friends
taking time out for casual conversations
allowing yourself to do things that just
allow
your brain to rest this is about
discovering
more of you who you've always been
and who you're becoming this journey
is not about the person sitting beside
you behind you or impressing anyone
this journey is about working to blow
your
own mind yes yes
with the way you love the perceivingly
unlovable
the way you forgive the perceivably
unforgivable the way
you bounce back the way you're you're
not worried about
not getting knocked down please don't do
that because you want to build your
muscles so when you get knocked down
don't
sit down don't take out real estate and
down
some people get knocked down and they
talk about it for the next 10 years you
know you could have got up right
they're just sitting there i can do this
for a while by the way they're just
sitting there
it should bounce back because when you
bounce back you bounce back with
something you didn't have before
so i came here and i'm grateful to be a
part of the tribe i came here
to not make it easy for you to sit down
to stir your soul to stir your love soul
to turn up something to till a soil in
you that says i am forever transforming
in this moment
the woman you've seen before the man
you've seen before i'm no longer them i
am transformed that
to have you fall in love with yourself
in such a way you only give yourself the
best version of
everything and everybody
[Applause]
see i i stopped by to poke you to pride
you to make it mildly to moderately
to significantly uncomfortable for you
to sit in any form of mediocracy
for you to to make sure you don't look
at 2020
when you get to 2022 and say damn there
was more of me to give back there
and i didn't to make sure you're
not keeping score keep track
but don't keep score make sure that you
trust your picker again
oh i didn't stop by for rah-rah stop by
to call for to invite out into the
universe the very best version of you
i stopped by to ask you are you willing
are you willing to do what you've never
done before say what you've never said
before
so you can be the man the woman you've
always known yourself to be
are you willing are you willing to to
tell any part of you
that doesn't serve your future any part
of you know the procrastination and the
and the worry and the doubt and the am i
good enough anybody know what i'm
talking about yes yes
and who can i be over there if i've been
this person over here if you're willing
to stop
and look at all of it and say i
appreciate you
you got me to this point
but in order for me to go further i'm
going to have to leave you here
because you limited thinking you
doubtful debbie you
naysayer you vision buster you can't
quite fit in my future
i have lives to transform i have people
to inspire
i have children to ignite i have loves
to create
i have so much to do i can't quite take
you with me but it's been real
we're talking about how to step into
your power
how do you step and more importantly how
do you stay in it
when things around you are turbulent
when things around you are
uncertain and when things around you are
constantly changing
number one how to step and stay in your
power
understanding the power you have even
when you don't feel like you have it
see power and your strength your
resiliency
your tenacity it's not determined by the
weather outside or the politics or the
social movements or the climate or the
health conditions
your power your resiliency is there some
days it's active
and you're living in your power you're
owning it you're walking with it you're
walking beside it you're walking in
front of it it's walking in front of you
power's everywhere around you
and in other days you have it but you
set it on the shelf
no one took it away from you i know
there are times we may feel powerless
but no one can take your power and no
one you may have to have reserve power
you may have to think about it
differently it may not be an act of
power
but power is always yours you're always
in the driver's seat of your life
and i'm not saying that excluding that
things may
happen to you but i promise you
that there's a point when you can slide
back
into the driver's seat number two when
you feel like you've slid out of your
power how do you get back in it
well i'm going to tell you from my
experience
back in 1997 i
had gotten into a toxic relationship and
the relationship left me feeling
powerless
my partner in that relationship turned
emotionally abusive verbally abusive and
then ultimately physically abusive
and at the end of that relationship i
felt like i lost
who i was and as a result of losing who
i was i was
just his girlfriend i was just his
fiance i was just
jelani's mom i was just this abused
woman
i had to go back and remind myself who
i am so whenever you feel as if you've
lost your power
really you've lost sight of who you are
and who you've always been
so what are the reminders number one
take post-it notes
with affirmations and stick post-it
notes with affirmations wherever you
spend time
so the first place i stuck them was on
the bathroom mirror so that while i was
brushing my teeth
i looked up and i saw a reminder because
you need reminders to get back in your
power
i saw a reminder saying lisa you are
built from greatness
lisa you're a divine being lisa you're a
child of god
lisa greatness is your birthright lisa
happiness is your birthright i would
look up while i'm brushing my teeth and
it was like something was reminding me
like oh yeah
i forgot that oh yeah i am
on my in my bedroom on my bedroom
headboard my bed headboard
it said you only have to accept healthy
love
on my headboard on the back of my front
door
was a post-it note that says you are
ready for the world
and the world is ready for you that was
1997.
like that's how important those
affirmations were in getting me back
up and getting me back into my power
turning my crawl into a walk in my walk
into a run in my run into a sore
and so if you want to get back in your
power begin to read things and write
things to remind you
of who you've always been you may not
see the evidence now
but it doesn't mean it isn't so second
thing
is to get people that can remind you of
who you've been
get people to pour into your ears pour
into your mind pour into your soul
i remember i was on stage once and this
woman yelled out at the end of my speech
you're an amazing mom
and this particular day i didn't feel
amazing at all i had been on the road
for 11 days and i left jelani with my
mom and i had never been
away from him for 11 days i felt
horrible
and so i felt like i was a fraud so i
walked off stage and i called a good
friend of mine
who's always with jelani and i and i
said can you please tell me
why you think that i'm a great mom
because she had told me that i was a
great mom many times
i said can you tell me why you say that
what do you see
and for the next 15 minutes she was like
i was like i need evidence
she just gave me evidence of what made
me a great mom in her
eyes sometimes you need to look at
yourself through someone else's lenses
because their lens of you is cleaner
than your lens of yourself
the third thing i want to remind you is
how do you live in your power
once you've gotten it and and while
you're in it how do you
live in it i'm going to be honest with
you because i'm your sister i'm not here
to just give you rah-rah hoopla
there are some days when while you're
living in your power
it feels as if you're getting further
and further away from it
and on those days remind yourself
and when i say power i don't mean a
dominant power i don't mean a power that
dominates others
i don't mean an egocentric power i mean
a power that keeps you in peace
a power that says i am in the driver's
seat of my life
i'm not a victim of my life every now
and then it feels like things like covet
or things like you know social injustice
or things
that are just happening around you
unexpected death of
of a loved one it feels like it throws
you over into the passenger seat
and it throws you into the back seat and
at times
it throws you in the trunk it's your
birthright
to climb out of the trunk climb out of
the back seat slide over from the
passenger seat
and get back into the driver's seat and
say this is my life
i have one thing that i run from
beginning to end and that's
my life and then just like how you get
back in your power the way you stay
is you get people in your tribe that are
cheerleaders
you get high conscious thinkers don't
get low conscious thinkers
low conscious thinkers will always want
you to keep them company
happiness is one of those conversations
that and experiences that can be a bit
elusive
because people believe that when they
found happiness
that it should stay forever and the
reality is
happiness is one of those ebb and flows
that happiness today
will look differently than happiness did
three years ago
happiness three years from now will look
different
than the way happiness looks for you
today happiness
is something that expands and contracts
happiness
is something that you bring into a room
not what you search for a room to give
to you
what i love about happiness is that it's
something that you can carry with you
it's like a light you know we have
people in our lives and
and you may be one or you may know of
someone where you step into a space
and you measure the joy in the room or
the light
in the room and then you adjust your
light accordingly
happiness is sort of like that light
then there are others
like i've learned to be where you step
into a room
and when you step into a room you
actually bring
the light in the room not that the room
wasn't bright before
you came but you carry your own palette
you carry your own storage
of happiness meaning your temperament of
joy
is set and decided before you
interact or engage with anyone
i'd love to share with you some of the
tools that i've used
to find my happiness that's one journey
to keep my happiness that's another
journey
and to get back to my happiness lord
knows
that's yet another journey so some of
the things that helps
with happiness number one
it's understanding the myth about
happiness someone else
cannot make you happy solely and
exclusively
they can add to your joy but it's no one
else's responsibility
to make you happy than yours when i
realized that when i realized that in
a parent-child relationship my parents
weren't responsible for my happiness
when i realized in a romantic
relationship my partner
wasn't responsible for my happiness that
i
lisa nichols i'm responsible for my
happiness
and everyone around me they add to it
in some cases they might challenge it
but
ultimately happiness my happiness your
happiness
is your responsibility so when you look
at
the journey to happiness or the journey
back to happiness
is there accountability meaning is there
someone in your life
holding you responsible for the person
that you say you want to be
is there someone in your life holding
you as the woman responsible for the
woman you wish to become
for the man you which you wish to show
up as accountability is
powerful in the space of happiness
because then you always have someone
reminding you
of your declaration to yourself
and then to the people who come across
your path
second is authenticity
when i realized how much authenticity
and living
in my truth had to do with my happiness
and i mean
the happiness that's in the dark of the
night when no one's looking
that not that happiness in the middle of
the day that yeah i'm happy
you know that happy that looks more like
this yeah
i'm happy how how about you whereas
people are saying they're happy but on
the inside it's like you're a ticking
bomb
it's like you're holding your breath
it's like the smile
on your face is for everyone else
and it's not for you it's that happy
that says i don't trust you to be able
to handle my truth
that in this moment i'm not i'm not as
happy as i normally am
it's that authenticity that leads to you
being able to say what you need to say
and do what you need to do
to be the man the woman you've always
known yourself to be
it's in not dimming your light because
you're worried that someone can't
handle your light it's in showing up
and standing as tall as you would stand
if no one were looking
standing on your tippy toes allowing
your greatness to enter the room
it's speaking life and to the person
you're becoming
it's also owning your shadow owning that
dark part of you that you
look back at and say i sure wish you
weren't there but since you're there i'm
going to deal with you
authentically happiness
lives inside of authenticity
and the third is can you be honest with
those around you
it lives in the same space as
authenticity but the honesty i'm
speaking of is the willingness to share
with people
who they need you to share with them
it's the willingness to tell people who
you see
it's the willingness to hold others to
their greatness
it's the willingness to remind others
when they're not playing as tall as big
as they can
and as they want to be remembered as
honesty
it's drawing a healthy line in the sand
it's recognizing that if someone keeps
crossing your line
it might not be because they're rude or
disrespectful
it may be because your line isn't deep
enough
it's not bold enough and can you be
honest enough to say hold on
i've trained you to believe that i can
handle everything
and that i don't need acknowledgement
and that i don't need to hear the word
thank you but hold on
i'm learning something from my coach i
really do need to hear thank you
i really do need a timeout periodically
i really do need my me time
it's being willing to be honest with
those around you
about how life feels in their presence
honest enough to say i love you
i need you i apologize
i got caught up in my ego if you want
some amazing affirmations with brendan
burchard check
out the video right there next to me i
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe
and i'll see you there you really love
marie and you want to do a good job for
her and her people
and this is a book you worked on for
three years and it's important it does
well
and brendan don't forget you're so lucky
you get to do this brother